single season records that have the
chance of falling now that we've gone to
17 games chris you have a trivia
question for me and i have a confession
i inadvertently looked it up during the
break because i thought i was asking you
so i've kind of cheated okay
all right well fine you could just take
the first pick then it was the prior to
the nfl expanding from 14 to 16 games
since 1978
who was the only qb
to throw i don't know the answer to this
yet you know the answer all right you
you then the question is who was the
only quarterback to throw for 4 000 or
more yards in a single season when it
was only 14 games you get the trivia
question i know the answer because i
looked it up uh well it's joe namath
right
yes i i was gonna go
joe namath or fran tarkinton i couldn't
remember which one it was
uh
but i i just i you know again i'm a
historian and i remember the joe namath
and just everything talking about that's
the reason people talked about him as
being you know the dan marino of his era
and everything like that
technically it's it's no one because
joe namath did it in 1967 with the new
york jets
that that wasn't an nfl team at the time
so technically
the pete's pete's making an excuse
technically
it's an afl record not an nfl record and
the reason i looked it up is last night
when i was looking at the records that
could be in danger i scrolled through it
pro football reference all the top
passing seasons all the biggest numbers
and i thought i saw none from the game
season in the 250
top seasons on there and actually the
one that's on there is joe namath 1967
4007 yards the other 249 top seasons are
all from 16 game seasons which tells you
what happens right especially for
quarterbacks when you expand the season
all right go ahead you got the first
pick records in grave danger now that we
have 17 games i think the first one that
jumps to my mind is like single season
reception you know uh for for a year and
i'm like right now michael thomas i know
is at 148 you know that's and i'm 149.
149.
it's an unbelievable number it is but
with the way we see quarterbacks
receivers throw the ball teams how they
feature wide receivers i mean we've seen
so many guys kind of flirt with the high
130s low 140s all of that type of stuff
i just go you give another a guy like a
michael thomas or somebody that's got
that type of offense one extra game and
one extra game could mean 12 14
receptions something like that uh yes
i'm gonna go with that one right now in
the 2021 football season the receptions
uh single season receptions is in
trouble
well and it's per game that's the key
9.3 catches per game got to 149 with 16.
8.8
gets you to 150 with 17 games and by way
of example the year marvin harrison got
143 the record that michael thomas broke
that average would have put him at 151
yeah so right that one is in is in
serious danger i'll tell you the one
that i would take is my first pick the
passing yardage record even though it's
54.77 i know i thought about 18 games or
17 games excuse me with 18 games it'll
be even easier with 17 games you need
322.2 yards per game to break it that
really doesn't sound like much
322.2 for 17 games gets you 54.78
no it doesn't sound like that much i i
guess hey that that's still a big number
you know as far as 54 5400 yards and i
mean what was what was our leaders at
this year as far as passing yards i'm
just pulling this up i mean we got to 4
800 right and this year where we talked
about defenses being a little simple and
not you know maybe being up to par with
the offenses early part of the year
that's still 7
hundred extra yards i i i like that back
prescott
even though he got injured five he was
on pace to shatter he was on pace to for
six thousand right but that was just
through four games yeah yeah so i i'll
be interested with that one i really
will all right i'm gonna throw one out
here
not that it and again i don't know
there's no guarantee that any of these
records fall this year
but how about
owen 17 yeah we got a new benchmark for
loserville in the nfl
will you be the first team to go oh and
17. i mean there was a time where we
thought owen 16 was really hard to do
and then we saw
teams like do it a lot over the last
decade and a few other teams really
flirt with it in a lot of ways so i just
think it's only a matter of time here in
the next two or three years before we
see a team to go oh and 17 and they can
become the new basement bottom dwellers
in the nfl
well and the browns of 2016. browns
ain't the browns 16.
that's right and the lions of 2008 they
can get together right and pop the
champagne when someone goes 017 unless
it's one of those two franchises which
for the browns probably not possible for
the lions it's at least on the edge of
the radar screen
next one for me the single season
receiving yardage record 1964.
115.5
per game breaks it 115.5 for 17 games
that breaks the record
i i i hear you i mean again with the nfl
the the passing numbers some of the
talent of these receivers things like
that
i certainly could see that there's no
doubt i mean
i feel like so some of the receiving
records
will be the quickest ones to go down uh
i don't know why but i just i feel that
way uh more than more than the other
ones all right you know you're talking
about 17 games i'm gonna go with michael
strahan's sack record you know at 22 and
a half i mean we've seen
people flirt with the 20s over the last
10 years i think it was two years ago
2018 aaron donald got 20 and a half
you know 2019 we had guys we had two
guys i think right around shaq barrett
had 19 and a half you give them an extra
game there
yes i'm gonna go with the the single
season sack record is one of the ones
that falls here sometimes in the near
future
and the straight hand record needs to
fall 20 years later we've kind of
forgotten about it but there's an
asterisk on that record because the last
sack was a gift
from brett favre who went rogue rolled
out in strahan's direction and slid yeah
so straight hand could touch him and get
to 22 and a half that that's that's
always bothered me that that
that's just it's just bogus he shouldn't
have that record and hopefully that
record will fall all due respect last
one for me
most games played by someone in a season
because there have been in the modern
era plenty of guys who have played 17
games because they've been traded
before their team has a buy
and after their new team has a buy
emmanuel sanders the most recent one to
do it others were will allen dexter
carter damon harrison jerry rice michael
ross will witherspoon all played 17
games somebody's going to play 18 games
you're right somebody's gonna somebody's
going to get traded but in a way that
they can that they can play 18 games
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports